alors c'est vrai que je vous dis nos
données personnelles sont en danger
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire rabat des
bois pour mine de rien protéger nos
données est ce qu'il ya des solutions ou
bien est-ce qu'on peut tous être à quai
voilà est-ce qu'on peut avoir accès au
téléphone de castaldi de normaux il faut
une confiance numérique une confiance
numérique c'est une hygiène par rapport
à ces ordinateurs à ses téléphones s'est
réalisé que il faut utiliser des mots de
passe sécurisés pas les mots de passe
partout les mêmes sur tous les sites
parce que si j'en trouve ans après c'est
à dire que j'ai accès à tous et il faut
utiliser des choses par exemple si riche
je vous conseille pas de mettre en mots
de passe lino 1-2-3 oubliant 42,3 pas de
choses qui se voit sous le nom de maison
exactement pas de chose en soi qu'ils
soient de la sphère publique votre date
de naissance le nom de vos enfants en
fait tout ça il faut éviter que moi
c'est ma couille 36 c'est vrai quoi
c'est il faut ils peuvent ils peuvent
tenter alors oui elle hésite mais juste
on a tous des box et d'où part la fibre
on a internet
donc si quelqu'un se connecte sur ça
chez nous aussi plus compliqué parce que
la nounou a failli s'effondrer sur
d'accès à internet
le chiffrement le système de chiffrement
de vos box sont quand même là c'est
solide ses tresses et relativement dure
en fait de hack in box internet est en
théorie pourrait se mettre avec un scan
de grâce sera d'accord bien sûr en
théorie oui avec un accès physique chez
vous si je viens chez vous pour réparer
quelque chose vite bien sûr voilà oui
alors une question de huy alors là je
dis vous pouvez à quai les modèles s
couacs et l'épisode wii concerne au
premier chef on a une super attaque est
régulièrement le régime si c'est m6 tout
groupe rtl m6
régulièrement on a des indications de la
direction qui dit si vous voyez tel
message suspect surtout ne cliquez pas
annoncé comment je sais moi que ces
suspects alors si vous avez gagné un
arrêt à jamais
question d'isabelle pour nos
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent en
direct juste rabat des bois c'est quoi
le truc dont il faut se méfier des
messages en petite hausse mais s'ils
ferment quand vous fait gagner quelque
chose
n'y a pas qu'eux après oui parce que
vous avez cité le cas de rtl m6 donc
vous on va vous attaquez on va vous
faire passer quelqu'un va vous envoyer
un message en faisant passer pour
collègues à vous par et essar que c'est
quelque chose de très ciblée c'est une
vraie cyber attaques sur un gros groupe
mais pour madame michu ou de citoyens
lambda là où généralement il assure
avoir ces ont valu besoin d'être cadeaux
n'hésitez pas à payer pour ça les gens à
payer étage est exactement plein de
choses en fait ouais moi on me dit tu as
gagné un truc je suis un rat mort avait
souvent c'est vous avez payé trop
d'impôts vont vous rembourse 100 euros
cliquez
c'est souvent ce alors les mecs sont
tellement contents les impôts me rende
100 euros et maquis clics tous
moi je connais quoi alors est-ce qu'on
peut acheter des choses sur internet
sans avoir peur de mettre ses codes tout
ça a été dur à saint raphaël il s'agit
pas de rentrer dans une paranoïa des
plus totales des sites comme amazon ebay
tous assez classique mais après il faut
avoir une certaine chez passé c'est du
bon sens en fait date à dire que si vous
voyez que le site
il pue de la gueule il a pas l'air
correct ne mettez pas vos informations
de sud accords sont pas les foyers sur
des sites très connus comme et aussi ne
pas cliquer n'importe où en fait les
néral manguy